okay all right ambassador how do you
feel about the diplomatic response to
Jamal Khashoggi x' murder at the hands
of the Saudis the Trump administration
response I guess that's what they mean
yo pathetic oh yeah we we've been
engaged with autocrats when we have two
international interests that doesn't
mean we have to check our values at the
door I knew Jamal I worked with him he
was a he was not some radical
revolutionary he was trying to do the
right thing and when we do that then we
undermine our values when we want to
stand up for democracy so you know right
now there's these events happening in
Venezuela you know we have stood up for
the the opposition there I support that
but it looks to the rest of the world
like hypocrisy when we do things like
that in Saudi Arabia yeah and and it was
only a few months ago and it's I don't
hear it about it anymore remember that's
not like he's out of power anything
happened to him remember that moment
when Putin and the Saudi gas hey with
both murder and journalists yeah the
murder of journalist club right Trump
wants to be a member of that Club so bad
yes he does
okay Heather how do you think MLK would
deal with Trump and the modern
Republican Party well I mean I think he
would think the Republican Party for how
much love they show him every single
year on one day it's unbelievable you
know you had Mike Pence throw in the air
saying that what Trump was doing with
the shutdown and what was in in light of
you know MLK's values I mean listen
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King was a
prophet and a leader and a community
organizer all in one and we need that
today he showed a vision of what this
country could be he brought everybody in
he wasn't afraid to educate people to
talk to
Rakhal so Trent white you know pastors
and priests and he wasn't afraid to say
that this country could be better than
it was and I don't think we have enough
people laying out that vision and I mean
it's a joke to pretend that the
Republican Party right now which is just
really remnants of sort of a racist
devil's bargain it has any claim to any
part of his vision
and they do it every single year with
Bertha but King said on more than one
occasion that the bigger problem was
moderate white people that's a problem
the big impediment to change right it's
problem right it's not that they didn't
disagree with them they just do anything
about right though you're rushing you're
going too fast
yeah by the way they spent two minutes
it is Memorial Trump and pence they were
they didn't have anything planned that
day and then they realized they could
lose their black supporter if they
didn't do something and they rushed over
there and spent two minutes sparsely
here they're just gonna yell out the
window okay Joshua how would you
describe the relationship between
journalists like yourself
and sources inside the White House on
the record is terrible off the record
it's great I mean we wouldn't know half
of we wouldn't know half of what we know
about what goes on behind the scenes if
White House employees weren't inveterate
leakers they all are and why do you
think that is because different reasons
ego to to stab colleagues in the back
it's it's sort of Game of Thrones in
there you know some of them just get a
charge out of you know seeing their
blind quotes in print or trying to
manipulate Trump that's another big
reason you know you if you get something
on the front page in the New York Times
Trump will read it and you can you can
help influence in that way I mean it's
it's it's more true of television
journalists and it is print like myself
but Trump's advisers will go on TV on
purpose to talk to him because they know
that the likelihood is that Trump is
sitting there with his TV on listening
to what they have to say and there
hasn't been a press conference since I
mean a press briefing since December
18th I think not a formal one but what's
what's the point I mean they get out you
know Sarah Sanders will get out and wide
to journalists there really isn't any
value so you both sort of agreed that
give you just gonna lie why do this look
it's more what neither side won't know
it's it's our job to show up and ask
tough questions and document what
happens
create a record of that you know inform
our readers and our viewers what's
happening but that can't be the only
line of attack or the only line of
reporting and it isn't I mean I think to
the great credit of a lot of people with
me not so much during the campaign but
afterwards I mean you've had fantastic
journalism in the New York
in the Washington Post we've done major
financial investigations at Bloomberg
into Trump into all the myriad conflicts
of interests that are that are driving
this administration and turn the country
to pieces but I want to make sure you
understand how crazy this is
I worked three years at the White House
for President Obama we maybe we were too
deliberative right maybe we took too
long to talk about things but we used to
sit in the White House Situation Room
and debate issues and then come up with
a policy and then you know we'd work up
the system and then the president would
sit there sometimes for hours to talk
about it
none of that happens anymore they rarely
meet he rarely spends time with advisors
he's watching TV and then on occasion
he'll get on the phone with a leader and
the leader will say hey I think you
should leave Syria and he said oh that's
a good idea let's leave without any
process in place and we now know this is
because two senior officials resign as a
result of the broken process that's how
a date for my world about national
security it feels really dangerous that
that's the way it works he knows more
about technology well that's right I
forgot
[Music]
can I just say people won't believe it
he doesn't use a computer and he has you
know no he has his aides go to Drudge
Report and print it out on paper and
bring it to him in a manila folder
that's how he reads the internet on fear
that people reads when it's his name and
piece of paper that we found out he eats
paper that he doesn't want HP saved to
the presidential record act he's been
eating documents where he's a lunatic
he's a loser
and the lesson of Trump I think for the
future is if you don't want to get
impeached 12 impeachable offenses a day
and you're safe right yeah any one thing
right this man had done some other
President had done he'd be out bind all
this terrific reporting everything we've
learned somebody else would have been
impeached by at a time do 30 and
peaceful things a day and you're safe
ambassador how closely is social media
monitored in Russia and do you think
Putin will attempt a crackdown on those
platforms do they have everything is
monitored of course right now David's
not like China where they they don't cut
it off yeah and and so far Putin's
allowed that as kind of a safety valve
for for the Liberals for the pro-western
forces to kind of tweet among themselves
the lower his approval ratings get I
think the more likelihood that they'll
go after those platforms and they'll
they like the Chinese model they'll
eventually end up like China they're
still really struggling with what
happened under communism aren't they I
mean communism made them so cynical
Ronald Reagan not my favorite but when
he said that was an evil empire dead on
I think I agree there's nothing that
there's nothing more corrosive to the
soul than living under a communist
regime and what Putin has promised them
is I'm gonna make us a great power again
right I'm not gonna you know you're
gonna be poor you're not gonna have
Goods you know that's the trade but you
can you're gonna feel great again like
you did during the Soviet era that's the
trade he's given I feel great again in
the green room thank you everybody I
appreciate it
you